digamos que la posición de una partícula
está dada por esta expresión de aquí
esta expresión horrenda que es menos de
a la menos t más sea la cuarta dividido
entre sea al cuadrado más 111 y de
mayores que 1 esta expresión horrenda y
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tratar de ver que podemos inferir a
partir de esta expresión acerca del
movimiento de la partícula como empieza
como se va moviendo si avanza ni
retrocede qué le sucede a la partícula y
lo primero primero que quiero hacer es
encontrar su posición inicial su
posición cuando el tiempo te vale cero
así que los invito a pasar este vídeo ya
tratar de encontrar la respuesta por
ustedes mismos si ya pasaron el vídeo y
ya encontrarán la respuesta vamos a ver
qué podemos decir acerca de la posición
inicial como decía la posición inicial
ocurre cuando te es igual a cero por lo
tanto quiero encontrar p d
0 0
cuanto vale esto pues sería menos de
menos de simplemente voy a sustituir te
iguala 0 menos de a la menos cero
- de al menos 0
más sea la cuarta base a la cuarta
todo esto dividido entre se cuadrada más
bien y cuánto es esto pues de es
distinto de cero porque de es mayor que
1 así que como d es distinto de cero
este término de aquí este primer término
es realmente de ala 0 pero de a la cero
como de es distinto a cero simplemente
es uno es uno ahora sólo tengo que tomar
en cuenta ese menos que tenía fuera y
voy a reescribir esto como sea la cuarta
menos uno
recuerden que cualquier número distinto
de cero elevado a la potencia cero es 10
a la 0 no está definido pero cualquier
número distinto de cero si así que esto
es sea la cuarta menos 1 dividido entre
pse al cuadrado más 1 ahora quizás
ustedes puedan notar que esto es una
diferencia cuadrados puede escribir esto
como sea al cuadrado al cuadrado menos 1
/ sea al cuadrado más 1 y como esto es
una diferencia de cuadrados yo sé que lo
puede escribir como sea al cuadrado
menos 1
por se al cuadrado más 1
esto es este término en el numerador y
todavía tengo que dividir todo entre pse
cuadrada + 1 ahora éste se cuadrado más
uno es distinto de cero por lo tanto lo
puedo cancelar o cancelar este con este
y escribir el resultado como se cuadrada
menos 1 así que la posición inicial de
la partícula cuando te es igual a cero
esto se cuadrada menos 1 se simplifica
bastante bonito
bien pues ahora les quiero preguntar ya
que sabemos la posición inicial de la
partícula qué es lo que le pasa a su
posición su función de posición va a
crecer va a disminuir se va a quedar
estática sube y baja no sé no tengo ni
idea de que haga pero traten de
responder esa pregunta que hace la
función de posición y bueno de nuevo los
invito a para usar el vídeo y asumiendo
que ya lo hicieron veamos antes que nada
noten que el único término que depende
explícitamente el tiempo es este de a la
menos t este cachito que acaba de cerrar
es lo único que depende del tiempo todo
lo demás se mantiene constante por lo
tanto sería bueno estudiar qué pasa con
ese término primero vamos a hacer una
gráfica vamos a poner
aquí me deje dónde voy a poner la
función de la menos t
y mi eje horizontal que va a representar
el tiempo
ahí está más o menos ahora cuando el
tiempo es cero de al menos t simplemente
de a la 0 que es 1
recuerden que d es mayor que 1 por lo
tanto eso está bien definido
así que cuando t es igual a 0 en la
función vale 1
cuando t es igual a 1
de al menos uno es uno entre d y como de
es mayor que 1 1 entre d tiene que ser
menor que 1 voy a suponer que uno entre
d está por aquí ahí está uno entre d y
la gráfica en la función pasaría por
este punto cuando t es igual a 2 pues si
uno entre d era menor que 1 1 entre de
cuadrada es aún más chico que uno entre
d porque d es mayor que 1 por lo tanto
por lo tanto pasaría más o menos por ahí
y creo que ya ven lo que pasa si
completarán la gráfica se vería algo así
es una función decreciente cada vez está
tomando valores más y más chicos por lo
tanto esto que tengo encerrado aquí es
una función decreciente
decreciente
pero tengo este menos acá aguas entonces
veamos qué está pasando con todo ahora
con
entonces qué está pasando ahora con todo
lo que tengo encerrado pero ahora en
verde pues estoy restando pero estoy
restando cosas cada vez más pequeñas
cuando t es igual a 0 resto 1 cuando t
es igual a 1 resto 1 entre d cuando t es
igual a 2 resto 1 / de cuadrada cada vez
restó números más pequeños a este número
que es una constante por lo tanto esto
como cada vez restos números más
pequeños si toma en cuenta al menos es
una función creciente
creciente siempre que tengan una función
decreciente si le ponen un menos
adelante se va a volver creciente la
gráfica de echo de menos de de menos de
al menos t se vería como el reflejo de
esta gráfica sobre el eje x se vería
algo así
esta de aquí sería menos de al menos d
bien así que cada vez estoy quitando
números más pequeños a un número que
está fijo por lo tanto esta función en
sí tendría un comportamiento creciente
toda esta expresión ya que junto a todos
los valores sería una función creciente
así que el comportamiento de toda la
función de posición está dictado por el
comportamiento de esto que está
encerrado en verde que es creciente y
por lo tanto la posición es un número
creciente empiecen se al cuadrado menos
uno que es positivo por esta suposición
de aquí y comienza a crecer ahora la
pregunta es cuál es el valor máximo
hasta cuánto puedo crecer o cuál sería
el comportamiento en el límite ok de
nuevo pausa en el vídeo si gustan y
tratemos de responder esto pues este
término en lo que está encerrado en
verde
- de al menos t es un término que se
está haciendo cada vez más cercano a
cero es un término que se hace más y más
pequeño en valor absoluto y se acerca a
cero pero jamás alcanza a tocar el cero
esta gráfica se iría así y se pegaría
pegaría pegaría sin jamás tocar
el eje así que este término este término
se acerca a 0 acerca
cuando cuando t
se va a infinito
de modo que si me voy a límites y me
imagino que pudiera llegar a este
infinito qué pasaría si te está en el
infinito entonces este término sería
efectivamente cero y básicamente tendría
0 + sea la cuarta 0 + sea la cuarta
que sea la cuarta / sea al cuadrado más
uno y ese sería el límite de la función
de posición sería un valor al que parece
que estoy tendiendo sin jamás alcanzarlo
porque está en el límite